Львівський вокзал звик зустрічати натовпи туристів. Нині тут тисячі людей, яких у вимушені мандри відправила війна.
Розкажіть, куди їдете, куди виїжджаєте? - Ой, куди потрапимо.
У Мукачево їду. - Чому саме туди? Там родичі? - Тому що там є вільний готель, тому туди їдемо. У Львові зараз, на жаль, не змогли знайти житло.
В Івано-Франківську область до рідні. - До родичів? Ви самі зі Львова? - Ні, ми з Києва приїхали.
- А чому тут не залишаєтесь? - Ну, якби до землі трошки ближче…
На досі безпечне Закарпаття і до Польщі курсують додаткові потяги. Потрапити на них можна "в порядку живої черги".
Ще один варіант - автобус, почасти - без кінцевого пункту призначення.
Автобус останній, який сьогодні є, на нього шансів майже нема. Квиток від тисячі. Їдуть вони самі не знають куди. Але через кордон перевозить.
До Варшави їду. Але я ще думаю, що я далі до дочки в Австралію. З Польщі я зможу вилетіти.
Мені от тільки перетнути кордон, щоб я до Варшави доїхала. А там уже мої внуки, моя дочка - вони мені вже зроблять все, щоб я могла полетіти звідти.
За перші п'ять днів війни в Україні прихисток на Львівщині знайшли близько 40 тисяч людей. Біженці прибувають до ось таких розподільчих центрів.
Потім волонтери й міська влада допомагають із житлом. Харків'янин Тарас із родиною їхали до Львова дві з половиною доби.
Жахливо було, і зараз жахливо. Нещодавно я батькам телефонував, сказали ХТЗ розбомбили, завод.
Поки не знаємо, що далі. Поки хочемо безпеки. Головне, аби дитина була в безпеці.
Донька Тараса - Каміла - певна, що до рідного Харкова ще повернеться. Адже там на неї чекають.
Там моя бабуся, дідусь, а ще мій папуга Кешка. До речі, мій тато казав, що наш будинок… Коли була війна, наш будинок не змогли зруйнувати.
Я думаю, що і зараз не зруйнують.
Маленька Катя у великому наплічнику встигла забрати все найнеобхідніше.
Миску, бутилочку, телефон, браслет, чехольчик и собачку.
Родина Каті приїхала з Києва потягом. Із ними в одному купе їхали ще п'ятеро людей. І наляканий кіт Пух, який не відпускає господаря.
Ми одну ніч в укритті просиділи. Наступної ночі хотіли вже в квартирі залишатися.
Але ухвалили спонтанне рішення спробувати виїхати, тому що дитина, жінки. А мені то що? Я назад повернуся.
Медична допомога, їжа, одяг - цього вистачає завдяки волонтерам.
Дуже класно видно згуртованість людей ще в іншому. Після того, як побачили новини про розподільчий центр,
сюди вже починають звозити гуманітарну допомогу, їжу, буси, пропонувати свої послуги, свої квартири.
У нас зараз на локації більше волонтерів, ніж людей.
За даними ООН, за перші п'ять днів війни з України до сусідніх країн виїхали майже півмільйона біженців.
Польща, Словаччина, Румунія, Молдова, навіть скептична до мігрантів Угорщина -  приймають усіх, розгортають тимчасові табори.
Ми з відкритими обіймами зустрічаємо українців, які тікають від бомб Путіна, і я пишаюся тим, як тепло європейці зустрічають цих людей.
Ми докладаємо усіх зусиль і збираємо усі можливі кошти для підтримки наших країн-членів на сході, щоб вони могли надати допомогу біженцям.
ЄС готується застосувати механізм тимчасового цивільного захисту - процедуру, яку розробили ще під час війни в Югославії,
але ні разу не застосовували, навіть під час кризи біженців з Близького Сходу у 2015 році.
Механізм надаватиме українцям право до трьох років жити і працювати в ЄС без статусу шукача притулку.
Саме така виважена реакція ЄС, на думку деяких аналітиків, є підтвердженням єдності Європи і ознакою того,
що Росії не вдасться розхитати ЄС, спровокувавши нову міграційну кризу.
Тим часом в ООН очікують, що кількість біженців з України може сягнути чотирьох мільйонів. На львівському вокзалі це відчувається, як ніде.
Але й тут знаходяться люди, готові допомогти тим, хто постраждав більше. Намети для обігріву й польова кухня - навіть із вегетаріанськими стравами.
Сьогодні ми приготували кітч, це така горохово-рисова страва з овочами, гаряча.
Ми готуємо на вогні, такі великі котли по 400 літрів, у нас такі казанки, у яких ледь не лопатою ми мішаємо ту їжу, ну, наші мужчини.
Насамперед це є гаряча їжа, щоб підкріпитись, якесь дитяче харчування, памперси, також у нас є спеціалісти,
які надають психологічну допомогу, також гостра потреба є у цьому.
Серед тих, хто виїжджає - жінки, діти, літні люди, іноземці. Чоловіки переважно лише проводжають.
Тим часом у львівській теробороні, як і вже в решті українських міст, на всіх добровольців бракує зброї - настільки багато виявилося охочих долучитися.
Волонтерський рух активно працює і в інших українських містах. Тут, у Вінниці, люди теж організовують допомогу і для біженців, і для армії.
Наталія керує молодіжним центром - у мирний час. Вона звикла організовувати поїздки та літні табори.
Тепер під час війни вона займається координацією волонтерів та розподілом пожертвувань.
Ніколи не могла уявити собі, що цим займатимуся. Ось навчаюсь, як краще організувати цей процес. Виходить... Все добре.
У Вінниці бойових дій поки нема, хоча періодично лунає тривога через авіанальоти.
Як і в усій країні, люди тут досі в стані шоку від нападу Росії. Кожен хоче зробити свій внесок в організацію оборони.
Суспільство накрила хвиля солідарності. Наталя постійно перебуває тут. Комендантська година вночі - єдиний час, коли її немає на місці.
Я не можу сидіти вдома і просто чекати чогось. Виїжджати я точно не збираюся, бо це моя рідна земля, яку ми дуже любимо, поважаємо, і ми тут залишимося.
Ідеться не лише про речі, які жертвують люди. Багато хто готує камуфляжні сітки для армії.
Зелений і коричневий одяг відокремлюють від інших пожертвувань і ріжуть на частини, використовуючи як сировину.
Українській армії досі не вистачає багатьох предметів першої необхідності, включаючи захисне спорядження.
А у багатьох тут хтось на фронті - чоловік, брат, сестра чи - як у разі Наталії - дев'ятнадцятирічний син.
Зв'язок є, раз на добу ми спілкуємося. Ці безцінні кілька хвилин, на них я чекаю цілу добу.
Волонтерська активність для багатьох тут - це ще й спосіб спробувати впоратися зі своїми переживаннями.